all right we're back on the Internet's
and I'm gonna ask you the first question
cuz I was just saying that you do not as
follow up on our editorial though you do
not have a photo ID that's true well I
do have a photo ID yeah you have a
driver's look but I don't have a
driver's license that's true I don't you
have a driver's close well I grew up in
New York City and I hate cars so I try
to avoid generally try to avoid driving
one myself as you noted earlier on you
don't even pull my people you know we
travel mainly by other conveyances for
example levitation magic of our pic
exactly exactly so you need overnight of
your people genies actually they rub the
lamp earlier today and then kind of out
I came Searsucker
sort of like this
welcome our next guest a wisp of smoke
okay Chelsea for you being the daughter
of a Mormon do you have any insight into
Mitt Romney's religion and how it might
impact his decision-making yes it's a
farce and it's a terrible religion and
you shouldn't follow it period what is
it worse than any other religion okay I
mean I mean any organized religion can
be very harmful but I think Mormonism is
really really ridiculous I grew up with
it and I couldn't even look at my mom
seriously for more than ten minutes when
she talked about it until finally she
just stopped talking about it it is
ridiculous even by the standards oh come
on but but it is but it's it's approved
millions of people's lives it's kind of
it's filtered tremendous ability of
Mormon families if you look at just on
the flourishing institutions they've
created it's an amazing can't drink
alcohol but the Preston Flynn is
speaking of sex the can of alcohol there
are a billion Muslims who manage just
fine without drinking alcohol they have
fun and they kind of coffee well they do
drink coffee but they you know the thing
I mean just because just because just
because the law under which Muslims you
know a purport to live says they can't
drink alcohol doesn't mean they actually
don't like that same with Norman yeah
same Republicans who have gay sex but
there's plenty of Mormon
but the press you think the Saudi royal
family doesn't have cases of Scott I
think that the Mormon Church it's
incredible the social welfare agencies
they've created just a tremendous
achievement the way that they've built
an institution in a very chaotic world
that has really been a source of Solace
and stability for a lot of people I
think that it's I just can't see being
dismissive but they don't accept unless
you accept Jesus Christ as your Savior
in the Mormon religion you go to hell so
you could be a you could be a great
person a huge philanthropist you could
live your life well not be a few a
philanderer get married take care of
your children and go to hell or but you
could be a rapist and a murderer and
accept Jesus Christ and then you go to
heaven that's not just religion but
that's my face away from Mormonism okay
and you were in it she was in it so okay
for Mark Cuban when will the NBA
successfully block the bulk of NBA
players from going to the Olympics and
why would letting them compete every
four years hurt the NBA so badly um I
don't know when it's gonna happen
hopefully soon because when you pay
somebody fifteen million dollars a year
and then they go and they work for NBC
for free it kind of gets under your skin
he's a good right waits a really good
point the Mavericks have anyone on the
team I won't let him know we didn't this
year yeah then what are you bitching
about I love you did they want dirt but
they want some no Germans didn't make it
fortunately oh that he would've played
for Germany right they didn't even make
it in the Olympics nope bummer Wow
did they innovate um yeah they did I
wasn't happy but okay um if the
government raised your taxes mr. Cuban
would you still be a billionaire still
create jobs and still invest in this
country absolutely I can take my taxes
from 35 to 39 percent I won't even
notice
yes all over out Eisenhower Eisenhower
it was 91% because he was a Connie you
know what it was leading up to the even
under Nixon it was over 70 and leading
up to the crash of 29 it was 25% for the
whole 20s right I mean I think so and
we're a lot more tax shelters each one
ten-thousandth of this country makes
five percent of total income this is
like end times imbalance the notion that
somehow they should be taxed less is
crazy talk I mean look here's the
reality if you have enough money in the
bank if you have money in the bank then
your marginal tax rate doesn't matter
either you're investing or you're not
you're not making decisions I've looked
at thousands of business plans on Shark
Tank we see 20 a day not one single time
if I ever had a discussion about taxes
and making those decisions not once they
don't matter either it's a good
investment or it's also will wealthy
more wealthy people should come forward
and say that they're willing to pay more
taxes I'm willing to pay more taxes and
I'm a Jew so
that comes up in this conversation one
that it's not about that it's about how
well the money is spent that's the core
question if the money is being deployed
effectively I would have no peyote Nandu
another stamp oh no no how the
Republicans are gonna spend the money
either you have no idea
sure you're just hoping they said I
guess in a case of five hundred million
dollars to Iraq and didn't know where it
went
that's exactly how that money was spent
yeah see you have here's one field for
14 years after the lease of your first
documentary oh that's a real fan Wow no
killer bid sure that's one person your
first like garbage the one there's be a
banned garbage yeah the brittleness
yeah it killed you yeah because we had
the name first and then they came out in
they used the same fonts it took all of
our air away oh wow yeah um right surely
somebody was delivery man yeah she was
yes they were good they were really good
uh do you think things are better or
worse when it comes to how Americans
deal with waste Oh much better much
better much better
yeah um cuz this we recycle and yeah the
recycling when we started garbage back
in 89 recycling in LA was not even the
little orange cart right thing and now
he got the big push carts but right now
waste is considered a fuel like waste
management is using looking at every
landfill they have and saying that's a
mine and so there's going to be Wars and
fights over waste before too long
because it's only it's all organic
carbon so they're gonna everyone's
fighting for I want to make fuel with
that waste oh I want to do something
else with that waste it's actually it's
I would be buying a lot of landfills if
I were you but about one they are
converting into land to be used for data
centers they go but when you converted
it Lighting's to data center you can
convert all the garbage on a date or and
keep the data say exactly but now we
need that to happen with water use
because that's an area where that the
amount of waste is this amazing stuff
with water right now there's there's a
group of people that are working on
treating you Nissa palaestra
so that you can actually take all the
water that we're using in our sewage
system save the water compost the human
stuff it's taking care of the bacteria
it's taking care of all the drugs and
everyone's a human stuff yeah all the
human subs use that compost for the
stuff I was talking about turn on the
saw
and salient green a crazy amount of
water rain it's people there's weather
alert okay that was hot look Chelsea
this is for you I'm Sturgis s do you
think Paul Ryan is going to be able to
attract women voters because he's young
and good-looking or is he a turn-off the
minute he opens his mouth Wow
see Sarah Palin I got it hello male
version of Sarah Palin I mean he's not
as stupid as she is but I mean who is
he's not as good-looking Hey right I'm
not that good-looking but she was a bad
good-looking either she was pretty more
than most politician was yeah political
women whatever they appropriate phrase
for that is but um no I don't think so I
think I've heard a lot about how
good-looking is now Allah tricks us I'm
not
hala trick says okay gotcha there's one
glance into what Paul Ryan has voted on
as far as women's issues this is the guy
that put forward a person right and then
on the floor of Congress right sua
systematically tried to defund Planned
Parenthood any lady that looks at that I
don't know how she's attracted to Paul
Ryan despite the fact that he does p90x
women who are pro-life I mean might feel
differently right I mean that that's
they exist and they're out there and
they have strong convictions to what
we're doing p90x to what isn't p90x it's
a game that he plays or know what's a
workout video intense workout video that
he bought on what what is that that
former shalls' infomercial mother I have
one I surely don't use it so let's go
put some money in a landfill yeah thank
you very much see you next week folks
Time with Bill Maher asked bill and its
guests your questions right after the
show
at hbo.com